cuando entré a la universidad los
gráficos por computadora eran una
técnica muy rudimentaria en aquel
momento
los gráficos se dibujaban con plotter y
en nuestro laboratorio de cómputo
teníamos un dispositivo que te permitía
dibujar una imagen con líneas fue ahí
donde aprendí acerca de las
transformaciones geométricas el álgebra
lineal y las cosas que se usan en los
gráficos por computadora porque teníamos
este dispositivo y yo quería dibujar
imágenes en él
cuando entré a pixar conseguí un trabajo
de verano en el que desarrollaba lo que
ahora llamaríamos tecnología informática
y que entonces se llamaba grupo de
sistemas
yo me hacía cargo de una de las cuatro
computadoras que teníamos en la sala
principal de cómputo ayudaba a
mantenerla en funcionamiento y en mi
tiempo libre utilizaba el laboratorio de
gráficos por computadora que contaba con
un puñado de dispositivos para generar
imágenes por computadora puesto que
estaba realmente interesado en eso
pasaba allí cada vez más tiempo y cuando
había que hacer algún trabajo en la
parte de los gráficos yo lo hacía era
muy divertido
es la mayor parte del vecindario de andy
con la ayuda de algunas personas que
crearon unas cuantas casas diseñé la
calle la carretera puse hojas en los
árboles y trabajé con alguien para
hacerlos renderiza bless también creé a
scott el perro scott empezó como una
escultura de gran tamaño la escultura de
un perro grande hecha de arcilla
polimérica nosotros teníamos que
encontrar una manera de envolver a scott
con una superficie de gráficos por
computadora preparar todo tipo de
conexiones y luego articularlo hacer que
se moviera ponerle los controles para
que los animadores pudieran moverlo y
luego trabajar con otras personas para
ponerle color y pelo
puedo pasar un sábado desmontando una
cámara para limpiarla y hacer que
funcione de nuevo a lo mejor elaboro
piezas nuevas con algunas de las viejas
que están rotas y las vuelvo a montar o
viajo por carretera y tomo fotos porque
no hay nada mejor que los viajes por
carretera y las cámaras